yes I was so excited when they call me
up and says Kenny they're going to
Washington DC oh my god I said and my
wife she was just excited as I was
[Music]
they greeted us and I even got a kiss
from Wonder Woman I musta shook about a
hundred hands I want to thank you so
much for your service in this country
[Music]
what we do is we fly World War two
veterans to see their memorial at no
cost to them it was the last memorial
built they are all in their 80s or 90s
and by the time it was built so many of
them either didn't have the finances or
they didn't have the family they didn't
have the resources to make the trip so
we make it possible for him I was
standing there and all of a sudden
somebody says death dead and they turn
her on this I recognize that voicing
there are my two daughters and my
son-in-law and the grandchildren are all
standing there and they run up crying
give me a hug and I have tears too
[Music]
got it talk loud because both of us are
yeah I went through France and ended up
on the German border and in the battle
of bulge and that's where I got hit and
I was a platoon sergeant over there so a
lot of men died and I think that's the
sad part because I got hit on Christmas
Day every Christmas I think of all the
guys I was with for four years and I
never came back I just choked up every
time I talk about
[Music]
I think it's an honor that's long
overdue for the veterans I don't think
any veterans get enough credit and these
guys are absolute heroes and it makes me
really proud to be there and share this
with my grandfather obviously the world
war ii memorial before was the first
time what do you think beautiful
I didn't expect anything mr. awesome
it's important to honor and to
understand the sacrifice that these
folks whose men and women they served in
the military during that time and others
gave to us are the freedoms and
opportunities that we have in our
country is definitely due to that why it
matters is its history it's something
that we fought for for freedom
[Music]
I feel like a king you said to me Tom
this may be the last big trip I take in
my life didn't you yeah
[Music]
here's flowing
so you know it means a lot to them and
it does volunteers to be able to give to
it it's just incredible it's been a
wonderful experience for us guys oh yeah
I met it I never knew it was alive and
it was unbelievable when they came up
give me a hug and say Francois we're
here just for you today that was my day
I mean this was a one of my finest days
I'll never ever forget I can't say
enough about it and I can't say enough
Thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]